good afternoon my friends still water
water
are you enjoying this beautiful day
[Music]
hi there everyone my name is malika
chopra
i'm so happy we can spend some time with
each other today together we're going to
be noticing new things
making some music
[Music]
nice song everyone and even trying
different ways of breathing
and speaking of breathing
let's start by just taking a big
deep breath
in through the nose and out through the
mouth
in
out
breathe in
[Music]
and out
okay
i think we're almost ready
before we begin would you mind gathering
some things to help with this experience
can you find a comfy pillow
a towel or exercise mat and a plastic
bowl and spoon
feel free to ask a parent or adult for
help
see you back here in about a minute
you have any old blankets
have a look in the shed
why hello there
[Music]
welcome there's room for everyone
[Music]
there now
have you found them great
this is going to be fun now take out
your comfy pillow sit on top of it and
let's begin
[Music]
hello there
welcome to a mindful moment with
stillwater
we are so glad you can join us
did you know looking and listening to
our surroundings can help relax and calm
the mind
you might even discover something new
so today we're going to use our eyes to
be mindful and notice the world around
us
there's so much color in nature what
colors do you see
green
brown
blue
red
gray
pink
ah
and look who added one more color
[Music]
can you spot the red trees and bushes
[Music]
look at the birds soaring high above in
the big blue sky
[Music]
do you see the ripples in stillwater's
zen garden
[Music]
or the rectangles on his house
[Music]
how about the rocks leading to his
bridge
and the arch shape as the bridge crosses
the creek
oh look
tiny footsteps in the snow can you guess
what animal it is
[Music]
it looks like a small bird
[Music]
watch as the lanterns start to glow
[Music]
[Music]
and the fireflies love to glow too
[Music]
ah the starry night sky
keep an eye out for shooting stars
[Music]
and make a wish
[Music]
great job noticing today so how do you
feel now actually a lot better i think
it's wonderful you've come out here to
be so present in the world around you
very good work
thank you stillwater i'm proud of you
for trying i'm proud of me too
[Music]
hi i'm kishibashi and i'm toby i hope
you like our music
kay and i love to play music we had a
chance to write music for stillwater
this wonderful show that's so much fun
it allows me and toby you know the
composers to really to have fun with the
music and we really would hope that you
would place them with us today would
that be okay
would you like to try
uh okay we brought our instruments
got mine did you guys bring yours do you
guys have your bowls and spoons toby
what do you think are they ready
let me see
yeah they i don't know oh yeah yeah they
got them okay but let's make music
together toby you ready i'm ready okay
well let's start with the beep okay so
you guys grab your bowl and spoon
and tap along and it's okay if you don't
have one you can also just clap like me
okay
so clap along because i'm gonna start
playing the violin ready great job
everybody one two three four
[Music]
[Applause]
now
oh that was fun awesome great job wow
you guys did amazing you guys are all
musicians here now i have a question how
did that make you feel um happy
calm
excited
sad
music can make us feel lots of things
the type of music that i really enjoy
sometimes is music that just invites you
to feel it just is this open invitation
to experience something i was about
seven years old when i started the
violin and i think i love it so much
because it's like singing
it's like
[Music]
it's kind of like uh it was really
beautiful to me so i've played it ever
since kaye and i actually went to school
together so we were growing up playing
music together playing music with your
friend is probably one of the best
things you could ever do there's like
one thing better than making music is
making music with your friends and
that's so much fun hey toby why don't we
play a game sure what do you what are
you thinking
let's try and name a feeling and then
make music to match it
interesting okay let's give it a try all
right well let's start with the feeling
of happiness you ready i'm ready let's
do it
you know toby why don't you kick it off
one two three four
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm pretty happy that melody really made
me happy tell me what makes you happy
about that yeah the melody made me happy
and
um the ukulele always makes me happy i
like the ukulele makes me happy too
ukulele's such a cute little cute little
instrument i love it
should we try the opposite sadness
let's do it
all right okay sadness here we go
[Music]
you guys hear the difference
quite different from happiness it's a
little bit slower
and there's some sad chords in there too
right
yeah absolutely you know sometimes it's
totally fine to be sad it's just that's
what we do as human beings if we have if
we don't have sadness how do we know
we're happy right every feeling you have
um is just as important as the other so
um it's okay to feel um any of those
feelings i've got an idea for the next
one how about excitement i need some
excitement good idea let's do it
[Music]
that was pretty exciting
that's that's how excitement should feel
sometimes excitement is hard because uh
it's really fast
so you have to kind of keep up with the
music so you're kind of running along
with it that's a big that's a big
challenge for me i almost dropped my
instrument sometimes by excitement i
have dropped my instrument sometimes
from excitement so that's that's the
danger of being too excited about
playing
so for our last one how about if we try
calmness okay that'd be a good one yeah
i need to
calm down here
[Music]
[Music]
that was a lot of fun
i i felt really calm what about the
music made you feel calm it was like
long and soft
nothing changed very quickly it was very
slow and smooth yeah it took its time
and there wasn't a big beat
and
it kind of flowed uh
do you hear that sound is that you toby
it's not me
i wonder where it's coming from maybe
you guys should go take a look yeah go
check it out let's see what that is
thank you guys so much for joining us
this was great we had a lot of fun bye
bye
[Music]
it is time for me to scoop leaves
would you like to help sure
i like a clean pond
[Music]
and so do the fish
[Music]
hey there
my name's jessica skye and i'm super
excited for what you have planned today
but first let's pause for a second
can you hear my wind chimes
[Music]
[Applause]
i love listening to that sound it always
makes me feel so happy and calm
and so many interesting things can
happen when we just pay attention to
what's happening around us
and inside us
like with our breath
let's try it together
remember that mat or towel you grabbed
earlier it's time to roll it out on the
floor
so free to move your pillow if you need
to
[Applause]
and it's fine if you don't have a mat or
towel just find a safe flat surface
now have a seat and get comfortable
we're gonna take three nice long breaths
in through the nose
and out through the mouth
[Music]
two more and do it with me
inhaling
exhaling
last one deep breath in through your
nose
heavy exhale through your mouth
[Music]
what are you doing
stillwater says if you have an angry
feeling inside you
sit still close your eyes and take deep
slow breaths
[Music]
it can make you feel better great job
now
breathing is one of those things that we
do all the time and sometimes we don't
even notice it
but
if you're not feeling great on the
inside taking a moment to catch your
breath can change that and
really help you feel calm is it working
actually
it is
are you ready to try something new
it's called
deep belly breathing and it's one of
stillwater's favorites
i like your big belly
me too i'd like you to put one hand
right here on the top of your stomach
just below your ribs
and when you breathe in
do it through your nose
and i want you to try and make your
belly
big
and full
it's like
a balloon and we're filling it up with
air
and when it's full
go ahead
and exhale super slowly through your
mouth
let me show you and then let's do it
together
[Music]
ready do this one with me
[Music]
[Music]
feels good right
let's do it a few more times together
just keep going
[Music]
[Music]
super calming one more
nice job filling up that balloon very
nice i think you're a natural next i'd
like to ask
what are some of the things you notice
when everything's super quiet there are
many different ways to be mindful in the
world around you
let's sit for a moment and
just listen
and i find sometimes it helps me focus
if i close my eyes
so give it a go
soften your gaze or completely close
your eyes
and just tune in with all those noises
around you
i can hear the water trickling behind me
i can hear the birds chirping in the
distance
and the leaves rustling in the winds
what can you hear
maybe there's a fan
blowing air in the background
a car outside
maybe your family are in the other room
and you can hear them
to take a moment
notice if you can hear
your own
breath
isn't it wonderful
now let's use our eyes this time how do
we start first
start with what you see
the shape of the fruit the colors
so have a look around
i can see
pink flowers
i can see green leaves starting to turn
yellow
i can see a red table
what colors can you find around you in
your space
what color are the walls
maybe there's an object on a desk or a
table
what color is that
maybe even look outside your window
notice what you can see there
there are so many colors in the world
to take a moment
taking them all in
[Music]
excellent job using your
senses now let's move on to something
new
go ahead and stand up on your mat or
towel
just like this
if you've got shoes and socks on
go ahead and take them off now
we're going to give our toes something
to do
all set
let's scrunch our toes up
and
notice what we feel
[Music]
i can feel
tingles in the tips of my toes
what can you feel beneath your toes
is it soft
is
anything bunching up between your toes
maybe you're on wooden floors
or tile
is it cool
is it warm
now let's move up from our feet
to the rest of our body
do you feel the air around you
maybe there's a fan or a heater and you
can feel it blowing air onto your skin
or maybe you're stood near an open
window and you can feel the breeze
coming in did you feel the cold on your
back that's my favorite part
perhaps the air
in your room is still
try moving your arms slowly around you
i bet you can feel the air now so just
notice
how that
feels it's like the air's moving out of
your way
just like ripples in a pond
all right let's do one more type of
breathing and this is a fun one it's
called b-breath that does sound like fun
so you know how bees make a buzzing
sound
that's where this breathing gets its
name from
we're gonna buzz together like little
bees
so let's take a slow breath in
through our nose
and then this time exhale with the mouth
closed and make a humming sound let me
show you first
[Music]
let's try it together ready
[Music]
feel how your lips vibrate a little bit
and it kind of tickles
you can even put one hand on your belly
like before and i bet it's getting
smaller while you're humming let's try
one more time
[Laughter]
that's good now i love how this makes me
feel
it relaxes me and it also energizes me
how does it make you feel how does your
face and tummy and chest feel now
it's always important to notice how
you're feeling
both on the inside and the outside
and if you're feeling happy on the
inside that's wonderful
and if you're not
that's okay
but if you take a moment to breathe
it can make you feel a whole lot better
isn't it interesting how these feelings
change when you give them time thank you
so much for sharing this part of your
day with me
see you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back
i am so happy that you decided to spend
time with us today and i hope you're
feeling happy and excited to discover
what the rest of the day brings i'm
going to try new things all the time now
and if you ever want to experience this
again
just remember
you can take a deep breath
make some music
or notice something new
hey look at this
there's much to discover in stillness
most of all stay curious about the
worlds and express gratitude for
everything wonderful around you it's
time to go now but hopefully we see each
other again soon
goodbye
goodbye bye bye
bye
thank you for letting me join you let's
do it again